[Music]
so my name is Philippe lemme I'm a
software engineer in android framework
team and I'm the technical lead of the
Android auto feel framework if the topic
of today's presentation so are about
today's to give a quick introduction of
wada on ride out of few years and why is
important for you to optimize your apps
for it so the end right out of your
framework is a new feature that we
introduced last year on the Android the
audio release and the goal is to provide
the safe and fast way for a better
manager to do their jobs so basically to
use out of you you need to select auto
service which is could be self that's
provided by the OEM and like a Google or
a few or Samsung pairs or they can
install a third-party app like a peasant
manager like LastPass - lame one
password in pairs and so many others
last time I checked there is about 30
different apps on the Play Store that
provides a lot of his service and one
key decision we made when we designed
this API was that it should work out of
the box if the existing apps in other
words you was an epidural upper you
don't need to change or app to support
out of you because if you don't do
anything
most likely the pattern managers will
figure out what to do for you but just
because you don't need to change it
doesn't mean you shouldn't after all
it's your app that's on the line and you
don't wanna depend on the third-party
app which don't have control over it so
the rule of thumb the main tip that I
would like to give is it should not rely
on lot of the service high risks rather
you should provide your own tip so that
you want to make sure that the password
manager or not also serves with their
job properly and you can do that quickly
or easily by just annotating your XML
views so the first thing you should do
you should make sure that you uh notate
what should it be out of field and you
do that using the Android column out of
your hints tag so let's take a quick
look an example let's say you have the
traditional username and password login
screen so if you're if you don't do
anything at all if you don't uh notate
your app for out of you and your layout
XML is using Android is like username
field and password fields most likely
isn't going to be worked fine because
when the password manager CDs you
structure
we're gonna be you some high-risk is I'm
gonna say okay there is a user names to
be string here in a password here so
they will know this is username and
password fields now let's say you are a
software house in Brazil and you like to
use
name is in Portuguese I actually grew up
in Brazil and I know this is kind of
common so now my research side these are
called come to Saguaro and campus saya
and this is total value from the Android
point of view so now the president
manager they will get this restructure
and they will know what this fields
means so basically they're not going to
be providing the RFU data and the user
you have to manually type in the
username and password which is deciding
the kind of problem they try to avoid
use a password manager so the solution
for this problem you simply annotate
your views so with the Android the
column also hints the case of username
is username and password use password
and Anjou dot Java we actually provide
hints for the common future because
their name Ezard credit card number a
telephone number etc now there is also
the other issue which it is you should
also note 8 what should not be out of
field and you do that using the Android
callin important for out a few tags so
just to see another real example when I
was developing this API last year at one
point I want to send an SMS to my friend
and then I got a pop up with my own
telephone number as a recipient of the
SMS that doesn't make sense right
because when you're set when you are
composing an SMS or email or a
spreadsheet editor
usually you you want to type something
dynamically you don't want to use a
predefined it values that pattern
manager has so this was kind of annoying
for me because I knew the API but it
could be confused for a user that
doesn't so the solution for this case is
simple should a disabled or a few for
your activity and you can do that all on
the whole activity layer by annotating
the route of view is important for out
of you equals no exclude descendant so
now not only you don't risk the present
manager provide the data where it
doesn't make sense but you also improve
the performance because they're not
reading out of URL so these are I would
say are my main tips and let's say I
convinced you to use this tags and you
are so excited to change your act or
going to skip the rest of the
presentation the the semi to go back to
a laptop and change your apps so now how
me don't don't do that but
how we're gonna change how we're going
to test your changes remember you need
to select an auto service to see what
would be the data provided by the
service and your first impulse might say
okay let me just choose whatever terms
with my device like a goo go to feel or
sense for the past or maybe install a
third party passer manager well if you
do that you could do that but again
you're going to go back to that problem
of relying on the password manager here
risk is in other words maybe they will
provide Auto Show data without your
changes or not going to really see what
was going always to make these changes
so my suggestion is to test using
standard out of service and we provide
some of them on the official samples
that is wholesome github so basically we
provide a couple of our food service
implementations that project one of them
is called basic service which is
basically is a service that only
understand out of you hints so if you
have if you're using auto few hints on
your app when the user click on a feudal
you're gonna see this pop up like this
like they did we know because you said
that this field is username you see
these username options on the other hand
if you're not using in this screen then
the out of you the basic service
wouldn't show anything this is also
pretty quick pretty simple service has
like less than 200 lines of code so if
you're interesting and understand how a
lot of the service work is a good
example as well now we have another
service that's quite the opposite it's
called debug service so this one tries
to show anything so if you don't use the
other two hints they still gonna try to
out a few based on your
restores IDs and this is useful to test
what would happen if you're not tagging
our views we've imported for all the few
vehicles no so for example back to my
SMS app you would see something like
this when you click on two you're going
to see these pop up with some user out
of you data which is two which is just
the name of the resource ID so you could
see how confused will before a user if
they see and then something like that on
their app now the final tip I would like
to give this you should also make sure
that our app works when the auto service
requires authentication so what that
means
well most puzzle managers they don't
return the user data right away because
the data might be encrypted there might
be locking somehow so they're gonna ask
the user to authenticate
user may need to type master password
there may be user fingerprint to unlock
the data and the way the framework works
we're going to be launching a new
activity that belongs to this service on
top of your apps stack so the user is
going to do the authentication and when
user finished your activity resumes so
for most likely apps this is not going
to be a problem but if your app is doing
something weird on the on the resume
let's say you're invalidating rebuilding
the view hierarchy or you uses some
webview to do some JavaScript code
dynamically so basically this you might
break it out of you as we're going to
see the next slides so again to test
this to make sure that your app works on
this scenario you need out of reserves
that requires a hesitation and the
simplest way to do that is using the
debug service so when you launch the
settings for the debug service actually
first you need to enable auto fuel and
select the surface so you can click on
the bottom and select debug service you
see the bug erosive service is one of
the options we provided that sample then
you can select this authenticate
response your options it's on the top
now when you go back to your app when
when you trigger out a few instead of
getting the data unlock it you're going
to be ahead get this prompt to
authenticate so when the user taps this
prompt we launch an activity in this
case is just ask for yes or no so now
when you click in yes in this case let's
say it in front is a screen shot I'm
using a sample app where I'm split early
we created a view hierarchy on start
so basically when I click yes we return
to our activity but now from the
framework point of view all the data is
different so they don't know that they
have the lock the data for your active
for your username field because it's a
different ID so it's gonna show the tap
to authenticate response again so when
the user click there it'll launches they
authenticate and say yes sure one
authenticate and then you go back asked
authenticate again so basically the loop
the user is now on this a groundhog loop
where it never goes forward and it's
kind of frustrating so the solution for
this case just wanna make sure that you
don't you create a view hierarchy on
create so now when the user is tapped
authenticate we still launch the tenth
gauge authenticated activity user say
yes now when we go back we show the
unlock data and the user select the data
and we are a few and everybody is going
to be happy
so these are my main tips that would
like to give from this session so
basically make sure you are not
interviews for out a few you test you
the standard services and make sure they
work with the service authentication so
I have some links here we have if you go
to the official out of few guides we
have plenty all this top because then we
have links for the out of your sample
surface as well that also has all these
apps I'm using I'm using final office
Humphreys so that's it they thank you
for coming and thank you
[Music]